J. MICHAEL MCBRIDE: Why do we
have nucleophiles
attacking things with leaving
groups on them?
What's the orbital that makes
those things reactive, the
substrate reactive?
STUDENT: A high HOMO.
PROFESSOR: Not the
nucleophile, the
nucleophile's a high HOMO.
It's a low LUMO.
So when you attack alkyl
halides, it's
because of the low LUMO.
When you attack alkenes, the
characteristic functionality
of the double bond is mostly
remarkable
because it's a high HOMO.
So we talk about electrophilic
addition to double bonds.
So it's low LUMOs that are
attacking
double bonds, like H+.
But many of the reagents that do
this, that are classed as
electrophilic addition reagents,
also have high HOMOs.
So they also function as
nucleophiles.
So the subject of the lecture
today is electrophilic
addition to double bonds, but
stressing that there's also a
nucleophile that may be
participating at the same
time, that could react with the
LUMO of the alkene, that
is, the pi-star.
OK, first I wanted to suggest a
problem for you to work on.
The pinacol rearrangement is a
neat rearrangement.
Notice that the way the carbons
are connected together
in the product
pinacolone is different from the
way they're connected in
the starting material called
pinacol.
The origin of that name is
interesting.
It comes from an ancient Greek
word for tablet.
And it was coined in 1859 as a
name for this compound because
its crystals were plates.
So it was called pinacol because
of the pretty plates
of the hydrate crystal.
But anyhow, see if this will be
good exercise for you, to
draw nice curved arrows that
start where they should start,
and end where they should end.
To show how you do this, it
requires several steps.
So that'll be fun for you.
OK, now last time, we talked
about rearrangement.
In particular, that when you had
acid reacting with the
alkene, you got rearrangement of
the product.
So for example, you add the
proton to get the more stable
cation, the secondary instead of
the primary.
But there's a more stable one
still, which is the tertiary.
So it involves a methide shift
that we
talked about last time.
And the product, then, when you
add water and then lose a
proton from that group, is this
rearranged alcohol.
So this could be a problem, if
you wanted to get the
unrearranged alcohol.
You couldn't do it by
acid-catalyzed hydration.
But there's an alternative,
called
oxymercuration reduction.
So the oxymercuration adds
mercury and OH
to the double bond.
But the electrophile is the
mercury +2 cation,
so one of the acetates comes
off, and you add the mercury.
And then there's a second
reaction in this sequence.
First, the oxymercuration, then
a reduction, which avoids
rearrangement.
So it gives the alcohol that you
would have expected if you
hadn't been sophisticated enough
to suspect
rearrangement of the secondary
to the tertiary cation.
Now let's think how this works,
and why it works here,
when you get a rearrangement,
when you have a proton.
The proton is small, and isn't
able to overlap well with both
carbons at the same time.
We talked about the fact that it
gives a double minimum.
It can rearrange.
Hydrogen, with its electrons,
hydride, can shift the same
way methide shifted in the
rearrangement we just talked
about on the previous slide.
But it goes over a barrier,
whereas mercury is a much
larger ion, and is big enough to
overlap with both carbons
at the same time.
So it's a single minimum.
Instead of rearranging over a
bump from one to the other
side, it lives near the middle.
So as shown there, now it's a
Y-bond.
The electrons that were in the
pi bond, on the carbon-carbon
double bond, are now shared with
the vacant orbital on the
mercury cation.
So it's one of those
three-center, two-electron
bonds that we talked about
before.
OK, so now, since the mercury is
bonded to both carbons, you
can't get the rearrangement.
Now here, we draw resonance
structures to denote the
bonding that we also can denote
by that Y, upside-down
Y, in this case.
But notice that I haven't drawn
it symmetrical.
The mercury atom is not in the
middle, halfway between the
two carbons.
We can have the three resonance
structures on the
right, with mercury plus on the
left with the primary
carbon plus, and on the far
left, with the secondary
carbon plus.
But that secondary cation would
be thought to be more
stable than the primary one.
So it won't surprise you that
the best position for the
mercury is not halfway between
the carbons, but nearer the
one on the left, so that it's
the most
important resonance structure.
And what that means is that the
cation is mostly on the
secondary carbon, and that bond
is weaker.
The bond on the left, the red
bond shown here, is stronger.
So when the nucleophile comes
in, in the second stage of the
reaction when the water comes
in, it attacks that cation,
not the other one.
If it were symmetrically
bridged, you would think that
it could attack both of them.
Maybe fifty-fifty.
But in fact, it attacks that
one.
So it gives this product, that's
the hydroxymercuration
product, the hydroxymercuration
addition to
the double bond.
That, then, nobody wants that,
but you could remove the
mercury by treating with a
reducing agent, sodium
borohydride.
And it's replaced then by
hydrogen.
So this subsequent reduction
step by the BH4 anion
completes Markovnikov hydration.
Notice that it's the same
orientation of alcohol that
you would have gotten with H+.
It's the more stable of the two
cations that you could get
as a primary cation or secondary
cation.
The nucleophile, OH, went to the
more substituted carbon.
So it's Markovnikov, it's the
same product you get.
But you suppressed the
rearrangement by the fact that
the mercury was bonded to both
carbons at once, and didn't
allow the methide to shift.
OK?
Now, this idea of bridging and
unsymmetrical bridging occurs
also in the addition of halogens
to the double bonds,
chlorine and bromine.
These are examples from the
lecture that Professor Siegel
gave last year, so they show you
the way you would write
this quickly.
And notice that the addition of
chlorine adds Cl and OH.
Cl goes, in this case, to the
primary carbon, and OH to the
more substituted carbon,
analogous to the way in the
previous slide, mercury went to
the less substituted carbon
and OH, ultimately, to the more
substituted carbon.
So it's Markovnikov addition.
Now what was the electrophile?
What was the thing that added to
give a carbon cation
intermediate in this case here?
OH came in as a nucleophile in
the second step,
and then lost a proton.
Water came in, lost a proton to
give OH.
But chlorine must've been the
electrophile.
That meant it was something like
Cl+, not Cl minus, which
you usually think about.
So let's contemplate this
reaction in
a little more detail.
So here's ethylene, viewed edge
on.
And an electrophile will attack
its HOMO,
which looks like that.
Now, the electrophile is going
to be chlorine.
Now, what orbital is the LUMO
of chlorine?
Cl2.
Arvind you got an idea?
STUDENT: Sigma-star.
PROFESSOR: Right, sigma-star
is it.
So let's draw the
sigma-star orbital.
LUMO is sigma-star, so it
looks like that.
Does that look good to you,
Arvind?
First, is the energy match good?
Is it an unusually low LUMO,
sigma-star of Cl2?
STUDENT: It's probably unusually
low, but it doesn't
look like the overlap is--
PROFESSOR: Ah, it is
unusually low,
because it's chlorine, with that
big nuclear charge, so
low energy.
But as you say, the overlap is
bad.
It looks almost orthogonal.
So what could you do about that?
How could you increase the
overlap?
Do you have any idea?
If you were a nucleophile, a
high HOMO, and wanted to
attack that LUMO, the sigma-star
of Cl-Cl, where
would you approach from?
Would you approach the way the
ethylene is doing here?
Where would you come from?
STUDENT: You'd probably approach
from the top-right.
PROFESSOR: You'd approach
from one of the
ends, where you get the overlap
without hitting the
wrong orbital.
So what do you need to do to the
picture?
STUDENT: Turn it around.
PROFESSOR: Right.
You need to rotate the chlorine,
because you have
poor overlap here.
But if you rotate the chlorine,
it looks just fine.
So now you can take the
electrons in the HOMO and mix
them with this pi-star orbital.
Which means, remember, there's
antibonding, it's an
antibonding orbital of Cl2.
So we can draw arrows like this.
Break the Cl-Cl bond.
So it looks like a nucleophilic
substitution reaction.
And what atom is being attacked
if this is a
nucleophilic substitution?
STUDENT: Chlorine?
PROFESSOR: The chlorine.
It's a nucleophilic substitution
at chlorine.
OK, so that's what we would get,
where the chlorine plus
has attacked the C-C double bond
and formed this
three-membered ring, still a
cation.
And chlorine minus has gone
away.
It took the electrons that were
in the sigma orbital.
OK?
So there's what's going on.
So if you consider this product,
the two different
species in the product as one,
that's the HOMO.
It's where the electrons of this
chlorine-chlorine bond went.
That top arrow, the curved
arrow.
And this is the HOMO - 2.
And that, you can see, is
distorted.
But it's the pi orbital of the
C-C double bond, mixed with
the p orbital on the chlorine,
or some hybrid orbital on the
chlorine, to form the bond in
the blue region there.
That's where the pi electrons
went.
But notice this is HOMO-2.
Where is the HOMO, and where is
HOMO-1 of this
product pair of things?
So let's look at it again.
Notice that there are two
chlorine-chlorine bonds drawn
in this three-membered ring.
So there must be some other pair
of electrons that's
involved, if we can draw two
bonds.
Where did those other two
electrons come from?
That other pair?
Well, we had the LUMO on
ethylene, pi-star, and the
HOMO on chlorine.
Now, what do you think the HOMO
on Cl2 would be?
Ruoyi?
STUDENT: A p orbital chlorine.
PROFESSOR: So
it's a p orbital on one of
the chlorines, an unshared pair.
In fact, we now want a chlorine
nucleophile, so it's
that unshared pair.
In fact, we want to draw the
molecular orbital that has it,
the high HOMO.
It turns out to be the analog of
pi-star.
It's not only the p orbital on
the bottom chlorine, which
would be relatively high in
energy, but it's a mixture
with the p orbital of the other
chlorine overlapping
with it, antibonding to raise
the energy.
So it's still higher in energy
than it would be if it were
just a single p orbital.
So it's this orbital here.
You see, it's precisely set up
to form good overlap, so its
electrons on the chlorine will
be stabilized by the LUMO of
the ethylene.
At the same time that the
sigma-star orbital of the
chlorine is stabilizing the pi
electrons.
So it mixes both ways.
The chlorine is both an
electrophile and a
nucleophile.
Two different pairs of electrons
are involved, and
that gives the HOMO-1.
Which you see.
So now we have two pairs of
electrons that are forming
those bonds, those new bonds in
the three-membered ring.
So we can denote that this way.
Now, where is the HOMO?
That's just an unshared pair on
the oxygen
[correction: chlorine]
that wasn't involved in this,
because it's orthogonal to the
other bonds, it's in and out of
the plane.
So that's the HOMO.
So we've seen the HOMO, the
HOMO-1,
and the HOMO-2.
There's the LUMO, which is the
antibonding combination of the
chlorine and the pi.
OK, so we've traced this
through, but the crucial
lesson is that there were two
reactions going on.
The chlorine acting as a
nucleophile as well as an
electrophile.
So although you call it
electrophilic addition, and
sort of imagine that it's Cl+
attacking, in fact, both
things are happening at the same
time, and two bonds are
being formed.
Now, what would happen next?
There's the LUMO, and we have
the HOMO of the Cl minus ion
that was formed at the same
time.
So if those two reacted in the
way shown here, it would be
the exact reverse.
You would form a new bond
between chlorine and chlorine,
you would put electrons into
this LUMO, this bond would
break, and you'd go back to the
starting material.
But there's a different
arrangement that will allow
you to go on from here toward
different products, which is
to move that chloride, an
independent ion, after all,
down to the bottom.
So now, we have that chloride
unshared pair HOMO and this
LUMO, and they can interact with
one another like this.
What kind of reaction does that
remind you of?
Did you ever see a reaction like
that before?
STUDENT: An epoxide.
PROFESSOR: It's like
opening epoxide,
which is in an even more general
sense, an SN2 reaction.
A nucleophile attacking a LUMO,
which is antibonding
here, and the leaving group
leaves, it's
an attack on carbon.
So that, then, would open up the
ring, and give an addition
of two chlorines to the
carbon-carbon double bond.
So you could think of it first
as addition of Cl+, and then
addition of Cl minus.
It's a two-step process.
But the interesting thing is
that that first step involved
both a nucleophile and an
electrophile
activity of the chlorine.
So we could draw it again here.
That first step, it makes two
bonds in the three-membered
ring while it breaks the
chlorine-chlorine bond.
So the red is what you normally
think of as an electrophile
attacking the double bond.
But the blue is a nucleophile
attacking.
So it's an electrophilic
addition of Cl2 to an alkene
that's both electrophilic and
nucleophilic simultaneously,
which generates this so-called
chloronium ion, this
three-membered ring
intermediate, which then
undergoes an SN2 reaction to
open up and give the product.
Now, remember, since it's two
steps, the nucleophile in the
second step doesn't have to be
the chloride.
It could be some other
nucleophile.
For example, you could do this
reaction, generate that
intermediate, but then have
water come in and be the
nucleophile.
In which case the chloride would
go away, and you'd lose
the proton, so the product is
HCl, the product
not shown is HCl.
But, you have the compound
that's called a halohydrin.
Now, let's look at the bromonium
ion, which you get
when you add Br2 and look at the
regiochemistry that's involved.
So you have this three-membered
ring, but it's
not symmetrical.
The bromine I've drawn is more
on the right than on the left.
Why would I draw it that way?
Connor, you have any idea?
Why not put it in the middle?
STUDENT: Because the carbon on
the left is the more
substituted one.
PROFESSOR: Right.
The more substituted carbon on
the left is a better place to
have a cation.
So you have a stronger bond on
the right, a longer, weaker
bond on the left.
So it's an unsymmetrical bridged
bromonium ion.
And then if the bromine comes
in, backside at the carbon to
do its SN2 reaction, you get the
product that's just like
the one we've showed before with
chlorine, except it's two
bromines that have added in this
case.
But that's only formed a 24%
yield, in this case.
What do you think the dominant
product is?
Antonia, can you see any
alternative?
STUDENT: Can you add to the
other side?
PROFESSOR: Well, you could
add to the
other side, but we've just been
talking about-- you mean
on the right, rather than on the
left.
You could, but that would be not
preferred.
You might say maybe steric
hindrance would help it attack
from the right.
But in fact, it doesn't attack
from the right, because of the
unsymmetrical nature, the bond
between bromine and carbon is
stronger on the right.
The positive charge is bigger on
the left, so that's where
the bromide attacks.
So it's not that it attacks on
the right.
But there's another possibility.
Anybody got an idea?
STUDENT: The water attacks?
PROFESSOR: Pardon me?
PROFESSOR: Aha, the water
can attack.
So in this case, instead of the
bromide, the water can
come backside to the carbon, and
do its trick.
60% yield, in this case, is the
bromohydrin.
So this is a competition between
forming the halohydrin
and forming the dihalide.
And notice that it shows
Markovnikov regiochemistry for
the reason we've just been
detailing.
That the electrophile that added
first was bromine, gave
the more stable cation, or
unsymmetrically the thing that
had more positive charge here,
and that's where the water,
the nucleophile ends up, on the
more substituted carbon.
But how do we know the ion is
bridged?
The same thing would happen if
we hadn't
formed that second bond--
right, if it had just been like
H+, if the bromine had
just attacked to get the more
stable cation rather than a
bridged one.
How could you know that it's
bridged?
What effect was there from
bridging
in the case of mercury?
Yeah, Arvind?
STUDENT: There'd be no
rearrangement?
PROFESSOR: There'd be no
rearrangement.
That's one thing you could do,
but there's another as well,
another way of showing that.
And this is the key to it here,
that it's
stereospecific.
If you start with the trans or
the cis-2-butene you get
different stereochemical
dibromides.
Stereochemically different
But we'll look at them in
another case here.
Suppose you have a ring compound
like cyclohexene?
And you add bromine, you get the
bromonium ion, obviously
both bonds in the three-membered
ring have to be
on the same face of the
six-membered ring.
And then, when you have backside
attack by the water,
it must form that compound.
It can't form the OH on the same
face as the bromine in
the SN2 process.
It has to be a backside, not a
frontside attack.
So whether it's the OH, and
you're forming the halohydrin,
or whether it's Br minus, and
you attack to form the
dibromide, in either case, it
has to be a trans product.
The bromine and the nucleophile
have to be on
opposite sides of the ring.
So an unbridged C+, the
nucleophile could have
attacked from the top or the
bottom if the
bromine weren't bridging.
So the bridging is evidenced not
only by a lack of
rearrangement, but also by the
stereochemistry of the product.
It's an anti addition.
The reverse, you'll notice, of
anti elimination, that we
talked about in E2 reactions.
Now how about other kinds of
reagents that can be both an
electrophile and a nucleophile
at the same time?
That do two things.
There are a lot of them.
There are things called
carbenes, there's the reagent
involved in hydroboration,
which--
things that have a B-H bond in
them.
There's a thing called a
carbenoid, which involves
these reagents.
There's epoxidation, which forms
the three-membered ring
with oxygen by a peroxy acid.
There's ozonolysis, O3 to form a
five-membered ring, initially.
And there's this thing we
referred to last time, where,
remember, H2 doesn't have the
proper symmetry of its
orbitals to add directly to a
C-C double bond.
But with the help of a metal, it
can.
And that's another case where
you have simultaneous
nucleophile and electrophile
behavior.
So we're going to go through
these, we won't get through all
of them today, to see how these
reagents work.
And finally, there's
polymerization, which is
another topic we'll get to then.
OK, so first, carbenes.
There was a fellow named Jack
Hine, who got his PhD in 1950,
and went to be a post-doctorate
with Professor
Bartlett, your chemical
grandfather.
And when Bartlett spoke about
this sometime, he mentioned
that the project that Hine
decided to work on, all on his
own, I believe, without much
guidance from Bartlett as a
post-doctoral, was the reaction
of chloromethanes
with hydroxide.
Now, by 1950, this was pretty
old hat.
Because the reaction had been
known right from the time of
Williamson ether synthesis 100
years earlier.
And all this stuff about SN1 and
SN2, E1, E2, had all been
done in the 1920s, '30s.
So this was pretty old.
Bartlett described this, he said
it was "about as earthy a
research project as could be
appropriate for a
post-doctoral."
But Hine knew what he was doing.
He had an interesting idea he
was following up on.
He found that the reaction with
hydroxide with chloroform
is very fast. With methylene
chloride is--
wait a second, I've got the
first one is supposed to be
CH3Cl I'm sorry, I put it in
there wrong.
So with methyl chloride, it's
fast. With methylene
chloride, it's slow.
With carbon tetrachloride, it's
very slow.
Now, if you were thinking of the
halogens as roughly like a
methyl group, which they're
about the same size, then this
looks like the same steric
effect that was well known
already in the rates of SN2
reactions.
That methyl is faster than ethyl
is faster than t-butyl.
So that much is sensible.
But what was interesting was
this: that chloroform is
fast. What does that suggest to
you?
We saw this before, so just in
general, you saw before that
when we were doing SN2
reactions, you had methyl,
ethyl, isopropyl, and suddenly,
t-butyl was very
fast. What did that suggest?
STUDENT: A different mechanism.
PROFESSOR: It suggested, yeah,
that there
is a different mechanism being
involved in that reaction,
somehow, since it doesn't fall
in line.
Now, what's special about that?
Well, he also could study the
reaction with this sulfur
anion, which is a nucleophile.
Hydroxide, smaller, better
overlap with
hydrogen, is a good base.
But phenyl sulfide is better as
a nucleophile.
Better at bonding to carbon.
So it's the thing that would be
doing
the SN2 kind of reaction.
And that is fast, slow, and very
slow, which makes sense
for chloroform.
So it's something about OH minus
being a base that makes
chloroform unusual, Hine
discovered.
So what it is, is when you have
a very strong base like
the base from t-butyl alcohol,
t-butoxide, it turns out that
you can extract H+.
Because the electronegative
three chlorines make the
carbon anion sufficiently stable
that it can lose H+.
It's not a strong acid to lose
H+, but it's much better than
having just two or only one
chlorine.
So you can do this SN2 reaction
at hydrogen and get
the trichloromethyl anion.
But then, it has a good leaving
group on it, chloride.
So you get elimination of HCl
from a single carbon.
It's alpha-elimination.
We talked about beta-elimination
before in the
E2 or E1 reaction, where you
take a hydrogen, the proton,
off from one, chloride, or
whatever leaving group, off of
the adjacent one.
But this is losing them both
from the same atom.
And chloroform is uniquely set
up to do that.
Obviously, carbon tetrachloride
can't do it,
because it doesn't have the
proton to be lost. So now we
have this divalent carbon, which
is called a carbene.
And it can come together with
the alkene to form a
cyclopropane.
So we're going to try to analyze
this in terms of the
HOMOs and LUMOs that are
involved in mixing the
orbitals of the carbene, the
dichlorocarbene with ethylene.
OK, so here are our reagents, we
know
the orbitals of ethylene.
So here's the HOMO of
dichlorocarbene, which turns
out to be a bent molecule.
And here's its LUMO, the vacant
p orbital.
Now does that look well set up
to react with ethylene?
To mix HOMO with LUMO and LUMO
with HOMO?
Noelle, what's the shape of the
HOMO of ethylene?
That's the thing that
electrophiles usually attack.
What is it?
It's the pi.
So it would be positive here,
and positive here.
Is that well set up to make sure
that this LUMO--
No, because the LUMO, the p
orbital would be plus on one
side and minus on the other.
They'd be orthogonal.
And the same is true, the LUMO
of the ethylene is-- would be
plus here, minus here.
And this one is symmetrically
between it, and they'd both be
orthogonal.
So both the HOMO-LUMO and the
LUMO-HOMO pairs are
orthogonal.
So it doesn't look like
dichlorocarbene should be able
to do this, to form these two
bonds at once.
But there's a way to do it.
And the person who can tell us
how to do it is Arvind.
STUDENT: We could rotate it
again?
PROFESSOR: Aha.
We'll rotate it.
So this is actually the three
frames through
the transition state.
This is just before the
transition state.
But notice the dichlorocarbene
is coming in sideways rather
than head on.
So that bond is being formed,
and the two bonds are being
formed, the pi are going here,
those in that hybrid orbital
here are going into this.
So we'll watch the motion here.
Back up, come forward again.
So what happens actually as you
go through the transition
state is it's rotating.
Because it starts getting
overlapped with the thing, and
then as the new bonds form, it
goes into the lower energy
geometry of the three-membered
ring, which of course has the
chlorines pointing up.
So then, this is the LUMO of
the--
I used difluorocarbene, to have
fewer electrons, in order
to do the calculation.
But then, you see that the LUMO
is the p orbital on the
dichlorocarbene, as we
suspected.
The HOMO is the pi of the
alkene, and they overlap well.
And then HOMO is that sp-hybrid
on the carbon, and
that's well set up to overlap
with the LUMO.
So again, you can do both
electrophilic and nucleophilic
attack at the same time.
But it requires coming in
sideways and rotating.
OK, now how would we know that
both bonds form at once?
Because an alternative mechanism
would be for this
thing to act as if it were a
radical.
For one electron to come in
here, one electron of the pi
bond to go here, the other to go
on here, to give this
diradical intermediate, which
then, in the second step,
could close the bond.
How do we know whether there is
an intermediate like this in
the reaction, or whether we just
have a transition state,
that we just drew, where both of
the bonds are
being formed at once?
What experimental test can one
perform to see whether both
bonds are being formed at once?
Anybody got an idea?
Chris, you have any idea of how
you can tell if two bonds
are being formed at once?
Pardon me?
Wells, you have an idea?
Have you ever seen an example
before where you could tell
that two bonds are being formed
at once, and not one
bond at a time?
Daisuke, you got an idea?
STUDENT: It's analogous to SN1
and SN2, so you could figure
out the rate.
PROFESSOR: Rates are one way
one tries to
do things like that.
Ruoyi?
STUDENT: Stereochemistry?
PROFESSOR: Stereochemistry of
the product.
Because if you have this
intermediate, if it lasts
longer than about 10^-10
seconds, that's how long it
takes a single bond to rotate.
Something like that.
So you could rotate-- this was a
double bond before, so these
two methyls were cis to one
another, both going
back into the board.
But if you get this thing with a
single bond, then it can
rotate in about 10^-10 seconds,
to have this methyl
coming out in front, the other
methyl still in back.
And now, you should do that if
you can, because
this is less strained.
Can anybody see why this would
be less
strained than that one?
Lauren?
STUDENT: The methyl groups
aren't
running into each other.
PROFESSOR: Right.
In this one, this methyl, is
between this
CBr2 and this CH3.
It's gauche to both of them, or
something like that, close
to both of them.
But here, it's rotated to be far
from the methyl.
So it's much less strained here,
when it's not between the
two groups, here, it's between
the CBr2 and the hydrogen,
although I've drawn it as if it
were eclipsed.
So if this is cis and it doesn't
rotate, this product
will be cis.
The two methyls will be on the
same side of the ring, both
going back into the board.
But if this happens, the product
will be trans.
So you do the reaction, and you
find that cis starting
material gives only cis product.
So there wasn't the opportunity
for rotation.
Therefore, it must have formed
both bonds either at the same
time, or within a really, really
short period of time.
So fundamentally, what you did
here is time how fast this
could have been, how fast this
closure could have been, by
knowing something about how
rapidly things rotate.
You know this collapse must be
faster than rotation.
So it doesn't really prove that
there's not an
intermediate, it proves that it
doesn't last longer, if
there is one, that it doesn't
last longer than 10^-10
seconds, which is roughly the
rate at
which you would rotate.
OK, now the second example was
hydroboration oxidation.
So remember we said that if you
had a B-H bond, you could
add it across a double bond, and
then, treat that in a
second oxidation step by
reacting with hydrogen
peroxide and hydroxide, and that
replaces BR2 which people
don't want, with OH, which is a
kind of compound
that people do want.
OK, now, so what this process,
the two steps, hydroboration and
then oxidation, achieves
addition of water to the C-C
double bond.
Do you know any other ways to
add water to
a C-C double bond?
Hydrogen plus and water.
That's what we added, HOH to a
double bond.
Oxymercuration and reduction,
which we just talked about,
also forms the alcohol.
Why do you need another way to
make an alcohol?
Sebastian?
STUDENT: It's anti-Markovnikov.
PROFESSOR: Ah, it's
anti-Markovnikov.
Let's look at how this happens.
OK, so here's the BH3, which is
an electrophile, because of
the vacant orbital on boron.
And this is the motion that will
happen.
These electrons that are in the
double bond go
in to bond to boron.
But at the same time, these
electrons, the B-H bond, an
unusually high HOMO.
Why is that unusually high, the
B-H bond?
The overlap looks good to me.
But boron doesn't have as big
a nuclear charge as carbon.
So it's a high energy orbital
for the same reason that bonds
in chlorine are low in energy.
There's not much nuclear charge
in this one.
So this nucleophile is attacking
pi-star at the same time.
So we can again watch this,
watch them stretch and shrink
as it goes toward the transition
state.
So we're breaking this bond,
forming the C-H bond, and
forming the B-C bond.
So, here we're looking at the
orbitals.
So the LUMO on the BH3 is the p
orbital, the HOMO of the
alkene is this pi, the HOMO on
the BH3 is that B-H bond, and
the LUMO of the alkene is this
thing, which looks ugly.
But the reason is that I've
distorted it, to be in the
shape it would have at the
transition state,
not where it started.
And so that was the transition
state, and you can see that it
mixes HOMOs and LUMOs, LUMOs and
HOMOs.
OK, so then, this then
establishes a B-C bond.
Now, the particular one-- it has
an R group on the B. Here
I've drawn methyl.
If this had been formed by
addition of BH to the double
bond, there would be another
carbon here.
There would have been a double
bond, boron added to one end,
hydrogen added to the other.
But I've made it, for
simplicity, made it a methyl
group, just so we wouldn't have
as much to deal with.
And now, I'm going to look at
the
second step, the oxidation.
So what's the LUMO that's going
to be
involved in this reaction?
Luke, what do you say?
STUDENT: The B-C sigma.
PROFESSOR: Though if it's going
to be
vacant, it's not going to be the
sigma, it could be
sigma-star.
But that's not the LUMO, there's
a lower orbital than
that of the boron compound.
STUDENT: It's, it's--
PROFESSOR: Derek?
STUDENT: It's bonded three
times.
Boron has a vacant orbital.
PROFESSOR: Ah, boron.
BX3 from last semester.
The vacant orbital on boron.
So it has an atomic orbital that
hasn't mixed with anything.
So the lowest orbital is the p
orbital on boron.
What's the high HOMO?
What's going to react?
Amy, you got an idea?
Can't hear very well.
STUDENT: The negative charge.
PROFESSOR: Right, the oxygen
that has a
negative charge on it.
So we can just mix those two.
OK, so we've got this, and now
we draw a negative charge on
boron, because it gained half
interest in the pair of
electrons that was on oxygen.
And now we have an interesting
rearrangement that
looks a lot like SN2.
Where is there a low LUMO here
in this molecule?
Linda, you have an idea?
Can't hear very well.
STUDENT: The O-O sigma-star.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, the sigma-star
of O-O,
because of the high nuclear
charge, like Cl2, or
something like that.
So low LUMO here.
Where is there a high HOMO?
Wells, you got an idea?
When you look at this whole
thing, here, what is there that
tells you that there
could be a high HOMO?
STUDENT: Negative charge.
PROFESSOR: Aha.
The negative charge.
But that negative charge is not
an
unshared pair of electrons.
There aren't any unshared
electrons on the boron.
So what is the orbital?
It has to be one of the sigma
bonds to boron.
For example, this sigma bond
here.
So here we have a nucleophile,
and here we have an
electrophile.
Here's the HOMO, sigma-star is
the LUMO.
Now, here's the geometry of the
transition state.
You see, what's happening is
that the CH3 is moving over,
taking these electrons with it.
It's a methide shift, like we
saw in the cation cases,
except that in that case, there
would be a cation here,
and the CH3 with its electrons
would shift, to give a more
stable cation.
In this case, it's because you
have the O-O bond.
But it's interesting to compare
this transition state
with the transition state for an
SN2 reaction of, say,
chloride attacking methyl
chloride.
So you can see, here's the
nucleophile, the leaving
group, here's the nucleophile,
the leaving group.
And in fact--
the sigma-star C-Br is being
attacked here, in that
reaction of the SN2, but in this
case, it's sigma-star
O-O, and sigma B-C is the
nucleophile.
So you see, it looks like the
same reaction.
And in fact, if we go to the
transition state, you see the
thing bouncing back and forth to
the transition state, but
if we look at the orbitals of
the transition state, this is
the HOMO for SN2, this is the
HOMO for this rearrangement.
You see, the orbitals look
almost exactly the same.
And if you look at the LUMO for
the SN2, and the LUMO for
this rearrangement, it's the
same reaction as SN2, this
rearrangement is.
So, this is the question that
Sebastian has already answered.
Why do this procedure, if all it
does is add H and OH to C
double bond C?
How about the regiochemistry?
And how about the
stereochemistry?
So that initial addition adds
BR2.
BR2 is now the low LUMO in that
initial addition, before the
rearrangement.
In the initial addition, B is
the electrophile.
So it adds to
the less-substituted carbon,
so that you get more of the
carbon cation character here.
And the hydride is what shifts,
remember?
It's the hydride that--
B is the electrophile, and the
B-H bond with the hydride
shifting is the nucleophile.
So it goes to the more
substituted center.
So whereas Markovnikov, of
course, knew nothing about
HOMOs and LUMOs, nucleophiles
and electrophiles, all he knew
was that the hydrogen went to
the place that
had the most hydrogens.
And the other thing went where
there were the most
non-hydrogens.
But the other thing in this case
is BR2, which turns out
to be the electrophile, not the
nucleophile.
In the other cases, the other
thing not hydrogen was the
nucleophile.
Now it's the electrophile.
So it gives the opposite
orientation here from what
Markovnikov probably would have
said, but for the same
reason that explains Markovnikov
addition.
And now, when we do the
rearrangement, what we do is
put the oxygen on boron, and
then have this whole R group
shift over.
But that's a frontside attack.
It's the sigma orbitals of this
R-BR bond that are doing
the attacking.
So it's frontside at that, it
comes in and the OH
replaces the BR2.
It's not a backside situation.
So you get that.
So the alcohol product is syn.
The two things that have added
are on the same face, not on
opposite faces.
And it's anti-Markovnikov. The
OH now is on the opposite
place from where it would go by
these other mechanisms of
adding the alcohol.
So this is a great boon, then,
if you're in the synthesis
business, and need to prepare an
alcohol where the OH is on
the less-substituted carbon.
So it's anti-Markovnikov. So you
contrast that with acid-
catalyzed hydration, which would
give this cation, or
pardon me, this alcohol, which
is the Markovnikov product.
How about the stereochemistry in
this case, is it cis, or
was it syn addition or anti
addition?
Did H and OH come in on the same
face, or opposite faces?
Cassie?
Can't hear.
You can't tell, here, right?
Because there are two H's.
So it's a clear choice in this
case, where it was
anti-Markovnikov. When it's
Markovnikov, and the H goes
where there are already H's,
there is going to be this
ambiguity, unless you did what?
STUDENT: Put a D in.
PROFESSOR: Put a deuterium in,
then you
can tell that it is syn.
But it appears random.
Oh, no, pardon me.
It not only appears random, if
you did it with deuterium, you
would find that it is random,
because you generate a cation
intermediate here when you add
protons first. And that could
be attacked from either side.
So it's syn here, but random
down here, and
that's enough for today.